was the tip of the finger found
it was found alarming details come to
light on day four of johnny depp and
amber heard's defamation trial depp's
physician dr david kipper says a chef
found his severed fingertip on the
kitchen floor in 2015. i cleaned his
wound to the best that i could i went in
to instruct
one of the
people with him to look for the tip of
the finger
hoping that we would be able to put it
back
was the tip of the finger found
it was found in the kitchen area the
pirate star alleged amber caused the
injury after throwing vodka bottles at
him which she denies and while the
doctor testified that he didn't see any
physical injuries unheard he does reveal
that he saw broken glass in the kitchen
did you observe any broken glass in the
house
yes there was blood around the home as i
had previously mentioned but i didn't
specifically see blood on
glass
there's also this moment where johnny
watched intently as a physician listed
off his medical diagnosis adhd bipolar 1
depression chronic substance abuse
disorder the defamation trial centers
around amber's 2018 op-ed claiming she
was the victim of domestic abuse johnny
was not named in the article but is
seeking 50 million dollars in damages
due to its effect on his career
including being fired from the fantastic
beasts film series
[Music]
do you think you can hold me
the exes have yet to take the stand but
last thursday amber's former assistant
kate james testified on johnny's behalf
mushrooms
ecstasy
and cocaine amber sat stone faced coldly
staring as kate listed off illegal drugs
she alleges the actress took and another
deposition tate played in court amber's
attorneys tried to paint kate as a
scorned ex-employee blindsided when the
actress abruptly fired her after three
years but it was abusive in your opinion
blind rage
multiple times screaming at me over the
phone
barrages of abusive
text messages between 2 and 4 am the
barrage would start in the courtroom
johnny appeared transfixed as kate
defended him did you ever see mr depp
break something intentionally never
break anything never throw anything
always completely passive depp lost his
original uk defamation case involving
amber and the exes have already
reportedly each spent some 20 million
dollars in legal fees
johnny is expected to testify on tuesday